I
[Music]
since this Universal is equally at the
disposal of the virtuous consciousness
and the way of the world it is not
apparent whether virtue this arm will
conquer Vice the weapons are the same
they are the these capacities and powers
virtue has it is true held in reserve
its belief in the original unity of its
own purpose and the essential nature of
the way of the world a reserve that is
intended to fall on the enemy from the
rear during the fight and in principle
to achieve that aim as a matter of fact
there for the night of virtues own part
of the fighting is strictly speaking a
sham fight which he cannot take
seriously because he knows that his true
strength lies in the fact that the good
exists absolutely in its own right that
is brings itself to fulfillment a sham
fight which he also dare not allowed to
become serious for what he turns against
the enemy and finds turned against
himself and what he runs the risk of
wasting and damaging both in his own
case as well as that as the enemy is not
to be the good itself for he fights to
preserve and accomplish that what a
risked in the fight are only the gifts
and capacities which are not themselves
at issue but these are in fact nothing
else but just that very Universal in
which individuality has been nullified
which is supposed to be preserved and
realized by the conflict but at the same
time this Universal has already realized
directly by the very notion of the
conflict it is the in itself the
universal and its realization means
merely this that it is at the same time
for an other the two aspects specified
above in accordance with each of which
it became an abstraction are no longer
separated it is especially in and
through the conflict that the good is
established in both modes the virtuous
consciousness however enters into
conflict with the way of the world as if
this were something opposed to the good
what the conflict offers to it is the
universal not merely as an abstract
universal but as a universal animated by
individuality and existing for another
in other words the actual good therefore
wherever virtue comes to grips with the
way of the world it always hits upon
places which are the
actual existence of the good itself
which as the in itself of the way of the
world is inextricably interwoven in
every manifestation of the way of the
world and in the actuality of that in
itself virtue he has its own existence
to for virtue therefore in the way of
the world is invulnerable all the
moments which in virtue itself were
supposed to be risked and sacrifice are
just such existences of the good and
hence are inviolable relationships
consequently the conflict can only be an
oscillation between preserving and
sacrificing or rather there can be
neither a sacrifice of what is one's own
nor a violation of what is alien virtue
is not merely like the combatant who in
the conflict is only concerned with
keeping its sword bright but it has even
started the fight in order to preserve
the weapons and not only can it not use
its own weapons it must preserve intact
those of the enemy and protect them
against its own attack for all our noble
parts of the good on behalf of which it
went into battle
we come now to this long paragraph
number 386 where Hagel depicts virtue as
in a sentence II and by the end of the
paragraph it turns out that virtue is
you might say on the ropes if we want to
use this this fighting terminology he
uses other fighting terminology talks
about weapons and about you know
something almost like a duel taking
place between virtue or a conflict or a
war and you notice that we've got the
same sort of schema as last time with
this Universal of the gifts the powers
the capacities the you know fake a
chiton and you know all those sorts of
things everything that we have and these
are individual right we saw in the last
paragraph that the individual is poised
you might say in between the virtuous
consciousness whereby they they
willingly subordinate their own
individuality to what it is that virtue
demands what virtue wants to bring about
in in the world or the lapse into the
way of the world which is just a whole
slew of individuality 'he's arranged in
different ways here Hagel will make a
contrast between virtue on the one side
and Vice on the other or if you like
goodness and badness or evil now where
the problem is going to arise is that
goodness turns out to be more widespread
than virtue originally took it to be
which in a certain way is good news for
virtue isn't it but on the other hand is
bad news for virtue itself in its
particular configuration and its
conflict with vice or the way of the
world selfishness individuality all of
those sorts of things now there's a lot
happening in this paragraph but we can
chart it out all using this this schema
so he says since this Universal that's
what's being contested right is equally
at the disposal of the virtuous
consciousness and
in the way of the world either one can
make use of either one can make use of
these capacities these you know gifts
whatever it is that individuals actually
have he says it's not a parent whether
virtue of us armed will conquer vice
whether virtue is going to triumph or
not you remember last last paragraph we
are taught over the last several
paragraphs we're talking about virtue is
having something like a comportment of
faith or belief globo right that's part
of what's going on and virtue thinks
that by having that it's holding it in a
reserve now this is a military term you
know literally that which is held back
from the action the action the conflict
is happening here you hold back a
certain amount you don't throw
everything into the conflict so that
when your opponent starts to weaken or
tire or make mistakes you can send your
fresh troops in sort of an encircling
movement around you know the back or the
flank or whatever you want it to be and
hit them when they're not ready and
they're there by you win so he goes on
and he says the weapons that these two
have are the same right through these
capacities and powers virtue has held in
reserve it's belief in the original
unity of its own purpose in the
essential nature of the way of the world
so what is this reserve what is this
hold out what is this secret ace in the
hole as we say you know in poker terms
and advantage well virtue has this
belief in its original unity it's ish
broom lika iana height of its own
purpose of its zach it's its goal it's n
it's it's what it is that it's to be
right so it thinks of itself as I'm not
like all that tawdry you know mundane
stuff that happens over there I'm
something better now it doesn't have
evidence that that's the case no because
it's trying to bring it about at this
point it has faith that that is
the case what else does it think it
knows the essential nature of the way of
the world the essence the vases and
height of the way of the world the way
the way the way the way of the world is
and let's remind ourselves what is the
way of the world well in a certain sense
it's that Universal ordering that we saw
which is unjust unfair you know based on
all sorts of arbitrary characteristics
you know who gets to choose things who
gets to decide it's not always on the
basis of who the most capable person is
or you know who merits it or anything
like that and everybody is sort of out
to get you know what it is that they're
looking for oftentimes it cross purposes
but that all combines into this way of
the world so he goes on and he says as a
matter of fact there for the night of
virtues own place in the fighting is
strictly speaking a sham fight which you
cannot take seriously why why can't you
take the the fight seriously you should
be taking the flight seriously right if
it's sort of up for grabs at the
beginning of this chapter and then
virtue has this secret reserved that
it's going to bring to bear the way the
world can't even suspect virtue says I
don't have to devote everything I've got
this in you know which is waiting and so
it doesn't fight in the way that it
ought to and it may in fact find out as
often does happen in military
engagements that the moment of
opportunity was lost that you actually
should have committed your reserve
earlier on so he says the night of
virtues own part in the fighting is a
sham fight why because he knows that his
true strength lies in the fact that the
good exists absolutely in its own right
there's a very important passage here
let's repeat that he knows that his true
strength lies in the fact that the good
exists absolutely in its own right what
does that mean it brings itself to
fulfillment this is something that is
that is
going to happen over and over again
we've already seen this a number of
times in hegel's text if the good cannot
become actual it is not really yet the
good the nature of the good is to become
actuality to externalize itself into the
world to reshape the world around it
after its fashion now sometimes when
that happens as we've seen in previous
sections it turns out that the good
isn't completely good that there's
unforeseen consequences we could say or
unintended consequences this is what we
call dialectical development right so
you you have an idea and as an idea it
looks really wonderful is you go to
apply it things start getting much more
messy and sometimes it turns out that
what you thought was good actually turns
around into something quite bad but
right now virtue things I've got this
goodness has to prevail and I'm on the
side of goodness right I'm goodness
itself now that's not going to hold up
for very long so he goes on and he says
what he turns against the enemy and what
he finds turned against himself are
these things these are the weapons the
gifts the powers the capacities that are
wielded by individuals wielded in
individuals the individual has to decide
am I going to devote these to virtue to
its demands even though that may mean
leaving behind my own pleasure or my own
you know hankerings of my own hearts the
law of the heart or whatever else it may
be you know my own advantage am I going
to use these capacities that I have for
that or am I going to use them in the
arena of the way of the world and
thereby become part of the way of the
world that's what the individual has to
decide and that's where the conflict is
taking place so he says what he turns
against the enemy and finds turned
against himself and what he runs the
risk of wasting and damaging both in his
own case as well as that of the enemy is
not to be the good
itself free fights to preserve and
accomplish that so we're where is the
good itself it's not yet we are going to
realize that this is the good itself but
right now it looks as if the good itself
is not yet there so where is the good
itself to be found well it turns out
that when we go to look for it it is
going to be in this conflict itself this
leads us to a very important point about
virtue as Hagel is describing it here
and let me remind you one more time
we're going to talk about this you know
in just a few more paragraphs again this
is not virtue as it would be understood
say in Plato or in Aristotle or even
arguably in the Stoics although an
argument could be made there this is
virtue is understood in a particularly
modern way where it becomes a bit
deracinated where people try to purify
virtue and extricate it from its social
settings and to say that we're going to
aim for the good itself so this is
virtue not so much even as say Hume
would talk about it although humans a
pretty debased conception of virtue
reducing it largely just to socially
approved traits and more like what
somebody like like can't might make of
it or indeed somebody like Rousseau
virtue is understood here as moral
goodness that has been purified of the
dregs of individuality of pure
subjectivity of interest of all these
sorts of things so what happens in in
the conflict he says these these are
right the gifts and stuff nothing else
but that very Universal in which
individuality has been nullified by
virtue which is supposed to be preserved
and realized by the conflict virtue this
is a problem with virtue right virtue in
the modern sense can really only exhibit
itself and no itself as virtue and
thereby discover itself in its conflict
with the way of the world which means
that it is as Hagel puts it here for an
other and insofar as it takes over this
part this is also for another which is
to be interested individuality is for
another it's not purely in itself to be
an individual is to be in part connected
with the rest of the world standing out
against the rest of the world right so
he goes on and he says this Universal
has already realized directly by the
very notion of the conflict it is the in
itself the universal and its realization
means merely this that it is at the same
time for another so here we get a
classic Hegelian reversal the two
aspects specified about what are the two
aspects virtue in the way of the world
in accordance with each of which it
became an abstraction are no longer
separated they're together in conflicts
to be sure but they're also together in
another way he says it is especially in
and through the conflict that the good
is established in both modes so there is
the good here but there's also the good
here that seems to be a problem right
because that's not what we started out
with this is where we see a dialectical
transformation you know we have what we
call determinate negation going on at
this point where you know not everything
is being negated but something that was
an important quality in the entire
structure here has now been turned on
its head so he goes on and he says the
virtuous consciousness enters into
conflict with the way of the world as if
this was something opposed to the good
that's where we started right what the
conflict offers to it is the universal
that merely as an abstract universal but
a universal anime
by individuality and existing for
another in other words what he calls the
actual good veer clica Guth oh right the
real we could say too if we wanted to
the real good the good that has been
realized why would that be the case well
again remember if the individual is veer
click real and the individual
subordinates subjects himself allows
himself to be nullified by virtue so as
to be the virtuous consciousness it is
the individual that is doing that and
it's not the virtuous consciousness that
thereby becomes good that's already good
in a trivial sense the individual
becomes actually good by doing so it is
through not just by you know thinking to
yourself oh I would sacrifice for
Humanity I would do wonderful things if
only what's given the opportunity the
means right the gifts powers and
capacities it's what one actually does
whether you you know go out and do
something to the person that you
encounter on the street or the people
that you're living with or the people
who you are for the time being stuck
working with or whatever it happens to
be right that's how you extricate
yourself from the way of the world in a
concrete fashion not a purely ideal
fashion so what hegel goes on and he
says therefore whenever virtue wherever
virtue comes to grips with the way of
the world it always hits upon places
which are the actual existence of the
good itself which as the in itself of
the way of the world is inextricably
interwoven in every manifestation of the
way of the world now that is taking us
beyond merely and individuality what
it's saying is that within the way of
the world we have all of these
individuality 'he's each of which has
its gifts
its capacities its powers its
possibility for virtue and each of those
insofar as they are like that are also
something good and so it's not as if we
have just you know the good guy over
here and everybody else is a bad guy
over here just part of the way of the
world as a matter of fact everybody over
here is living sort of a double life in
a sense they're bad because they're
following their self-interest or their
you know if we want to be contient about
it they're their happiness right and
what is happiness the satisfaction of
all of our desires and inclinations you
know which is subjective there is a
certain general ground to it but it's
not pure is that universal in the way
that can't wants it but what Hagel's
recognizing here is though if the world
is now revealing that it's made up of
all these goods actual goods right
individuality that are actual goods
vehicle eeka buta buta so he goes on and
now this leads to a problem he says in
the actuality of that virtue he has its
own existence to for virtue therefore
the way of the world is invulnerable
virtue was going to come and use this
reserve to attack the way of the world
and now it turns out that the way of the
world isn't really vulnerable to virtue
why because virtue only strikes down
what is bad what is evil it will it will
enter into conflict but only strike the
blow where it's needed so insofar as
there are some good some actual goods in
all those individuality 'he's comprising
the way of the world it finds itself
paralyzed and that's the virtuous
consciousness that finds itself
paralyzed you know you want to change
things in a fundamental way and then you
find out that those that you're fighting
against aren't really is bad as you
and you're incapacitated against them so
he goes on and he says all the moments
in which virtue were supposed to be
risked and sacrificed are just such
existences of the good and hence are
inviolable relationships consequently
the conflict can only be an oscillation
of going back and forth not a resolution
between preserving and sacrificing or
rather there can neither be a sacrifice
of what is one's own on the side of
virtue nor a violation of what is alien
so here's where Hagel has a really
interesting metaphor in martial arts you
know a lot of times in martial arts
we're not actually fighting with weapons
we're using our body and that would be
more like what Hagel's talking about
here is capacities right and you get
people who like to you know train a lot
but when it comes time to actually spar
let alone to actually go into a fight
they don't want to you know they'll
throw punches and kicks but they're not
really trying to connect why not because
maybe they'd hurt their foot or their
hand or whatever or you know maybe the
opponent doesn't really deserve it well
you're not going to be a very good
martial artist if that's what you're
what you're doing and that's what he
calls a sham fight so Hagel here talks
about virtue being like the combatant
who in the conflict is only concerned
with keeping his sword bright he doesn't
want to get it nicked or notched right
or let alone covered with blood but it
goes beyond that he even started the
fight in order to preserve the weapons
that's a little bit different it got
into the fight for a purpose that
contradicts what you've got the weapons
for in the first place you know there's
this the Civil War general who was an
old story I don't remember which general
it is but a young cavalry officer found
this general sharpening his saber before
a battle and the young
stir was like man this guy you know he's
a general he shouldn't be doing that
he's never going to use his saber why is
he bothering with that he's wasting his
time so he goes up to him like young
people are prone to do he says you know
sure what are you doing there and you
know they have a little conversation and
it ends with the general saying fighting
is for killing son namely if you're
going to have weapons there to be used
right that's the point of having weapons
that's the point of having these
capacities you know if you're holding
everything in reserve going into a
combat just to try to preserve that
reserve and never actually using it is
not a very good strategy is it so he
goes not only can it not use its own
weapons even beyond that it must
preserve and tack those of the enemy and
protect them against its own attack for
all our noble parts of the good on
behalf of which it went into battle
insofar as it discovers the goodness
various goodness's actual goodness's of
human beings in those who are part of
the way of the world it cannot take
action against them so like I said it's
paralyzed it's ineffectual now this is
going to be a problem right because
isn't virtue supposed to be the good
precisely by actual izing the good
you